no cop no firefighter no nurse nobody
should be losing their jobs because of
these jabs we have got to stand up for
people and protect their jobs and
protect
they're doing their livelihoods
so there's there's going to be a battle
here and that's the florida governor ron
desantis in florida taking legal action
against president biden's workplace
vaccine mandates the state filing a
lawsuit claiming the order is out of
bounds with us now florida a.g ashley
moody thank you for your time good
morning to you make your case
good morning i mean the case is simple
this is the playbook of this unlawful
bind administration they know this is
illegal they know osha has no authority
whatsoever to mandate these vaccines so
they go to an emergency rule
as they have done with so many things
they unlawfully mandate things on the
american people and they say that in
order to
make workers themselves safe on the job
sites we have to enact widespread
health care policy and forcing folks to
either lose their job or give up their
health care autonomy it's unconscionable
it's reprehensible and governor desantis
and i will continue to push back okay
i'll get back to the government a moment
here's what the white house's position
is just from this week watch here
and we believe
that in order to get this pandemic
behind us we get we need to get more
people vaccinated and this is a way
to do that we feel confident about the
the legal component of this the
department of labor have the has the
authority
to move forward in making sure that they
keep the workplace safe
and so uh yeah we have to make sure that
we get this pandemic behind so the point
there is that there's no turning back
this is the only way florida you joined
georgia and alabama to file that
challenge on friday respond to the white
house there if you will
look florida is leading that charge
along with georgia and alabama down here
in the 11th circuit it's an admission
right there they tell you this is not
about the individual circumstances and
the safety of those
employees on those job sites they're
like we're doing this because we cannot
we have been unable to come up with some
strategic thoughtful common sense policy
that's within lawful bounds so we're
going to violate the law use osha to do
what we know we can't do that obliterate
separation of powers and it's unlawful
and will continue to push back okay
another topic here apparently there's
these flights that are landing i think
in jacksonville specifically uh governor
desantis on with tucker last night made
the case against them watch
these midnight flights unannounced no
notice no support for the state no
ability for us to veto it ahead of time
and if if biden had not been doing that
if he'd been doing his job that
individual be alive today okay he's
talking about that illegal immigrant
charge of the murder there now on these
flights with regard to these flights
how many are there how many have come to
florida what are the facts on that
and you have hit the nail on the head
that's the problem continuing with this
administration's theme they are
completely violating ignoring the law as
it relates to immigration as you know
florida was one of the first states to
bring suit
requiring them to follow the law make
sure that we know we know we've seen a
drastic increase in those coming across
and flooding our borders that have
serious criminal convictions we need to
know who's coming into our state so that
we can protect the citizens of our state
as we've taken an oath to do and this
administration seems to have no regard
for the safety or well-being of
law-abiding citizens as you can see in
in the both of these recent actions
we've been talking about today um this
uh illegal charge with murder was this
illegal indeed on one of those flights
into jacksonville
this is part of our suits where we are
demanding that the federal government
share this information with us they are
trying to hide from the american people
that are they are continuously violating
the law not letting the states know what
they're doing and putting many of these
communities at risk many of the
immigrant communities in florida we are
a welcoming state we're a diverse state
but we need to be able to do our jobs as
leaders and protect our citizens this
administration is tying our hands and
those of law enforcement just uh just to
nail this down was that illegal on a
flight into florida did that happen is
that how we got there
i will tell you that we are delving deep
into this and this will be part of what
we do and pushing the courts to grant
our state relief and force the federal
government to follow the law okay so um
i'll take it as a non-answer we'll try
and figure out that fact uh when we can
fair
thanks so much i appreciate it ashley
moody thank you the ag there in florida
thank you for your time today